I normally don't like to dive in on like
sequels and all that stuff but I can see
this being a really big hit if they if
it ends up being a really big hit is
this something that you've thought about
like would we want to do another yes yes
we have we're currently negotiating with
sister Phegley I know we have I think we
would all do it again in a minute you
know it the staffs already started work
on another script and and I think
there's so much material in the books I
mean he's written how many people said
oh yeah and there's so many great
characters and so many recurring
characters so look I think whenever you
talk about a sequel it's like do people
want to come back and spend time with
the characters and I think when I watch
the movie now that's one thing I really
feel satisfied by watching it is how
many different characters there are
they're fun to spend time with so that
to me is it's a good thing so I would
not rule that out I was gonna say one of
the things that's great is this is a
complete story beginning middle and end
so it's you know it's but it leaves room
if you want it to continue I wanted to
just ask you with the you have a number
of things you could pick from do you
have the one that you does the if you
were to be say making a sequel do you
have the title do you know which one it
is
yes I understand yeah it's a combination
I mean the series is is seven books sure
so if I had my way the sequel is a bit
of a combination of two three and four
sort of put together truncated so yeah I
mean it's really for me it was a matter
of finding what new character that
wasn't in one would make this really
interesting so I think I found that
character from one of the books and so
yeah it's fun it's fun I like exploring
I mean for me I was saying to Tom with
the sequel part of the fun is we've seen
him interact with certain age
classifications and there was this one
that we hadn't seen what would he be
like around this type of person so the
character that I was focusing on for the
sequel is this character from one of the
books that it would be fun to just see
so I just kind of like to bounce him off
of you know different roles I'm just
wondering if that person would be in
high school
now that person would be old yes got it
okay yes